Next, we'll create the Today List Item.
Since this layout is different
from the other list items, we're going
to need to create a new XML file under
the resources layout folder. Use the same
place holder image as you did before.
Also, use the same IDs
that you declared in the
list_item_forecast_xml file.
For example, in our code,
we called this list item Icon,
and we called this list item
Date Text View.
So, we use those same IDs
for the elements in this XML file.
You'll see why when we introduce
view holders later.
After you've finished adding it,
make sure the app still compiles.
You won't see any visual difference
until the next step.